From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
She was a real, she never stopped talking.
And she...
All right, Mrs. Roxbury, Mr. Bob, recording.
Okay.
We begin the interview.
Okay, ready to go?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
Mrs. Roxbury, you were born into an African American family that was aware of the need to do what was necessary to improve the quality of their daily lives.
Can you share with us how your family made changes in their lives to improve their situation?
Well, we lived in one of the three counties in the state of Tennessee in which blacks did not vote.
So, one of the things my parents felt, which would be a paramount importance, was to get the right to vote.
And they proceeded to campaign for that purpose by getting other people in the community to join them to go to the county courthouse to register to vote.
And that was a primary ingredient.
And this is before they organized a branch of the NAACP.
And of course, they also felt that the community of blacks in the county,
Heywood County was the county in which we lived.
The county seat was Brownsville in which I was born.
And of course, they felt that it was important to organize our black citizens because they outnumbered the white citizens by three to one.
And that if they could marshal the black citizens in greater strength, they could change the quality of our lives to some extent by exercising political power.
Did you ever hear your parents talk about organizing the first NAACP chapter in Brownsville? Did you ever hear them discuss it?
Oh yes.
What do they have to say?
Well, they said that we needed to have people who would be able to withstand the pressures which they anticipated would be applied when we started formal, when they started formally organizing a group together instead of having an individual who would join them on certain occasions.
And in order to do this, at that time, as I recall, Walter White was executive secretary of the NAACP.
And I would hear his name frequently saying, we've got to get Walter White to send us a charter to authorize a charter for our unit.
And then they wrote away to get enough information about the number of people who would be required.
And there was much discussion when I was a youngster.
I suppose about this time, I was about seven years of age at that time, having been reading the crisis because they subscribed to it.
So I was well aware of what the NAACP was in my own perspective.
Now, you were nine years old when you first became involved with the NAACP. What led you to your involvement and what led you to be willing to sell the crisis? To sell subscriptions?
Well, well, my parents were teachers. And my mother, there were three of us, of which I was the youngest.
And my mother or my father, virtually every evening before I went to bed, would read poetry and excerpts from history and things events to my sisters.
And I would be sitting on my mother's lap. And oftentimes in reading poetry, she would quote to them saying that this is a piece by Langston Hughes, which was published in the crisis magazine.
And of course, I wanted to know what the crisis was after having heard us say that so often.
And she said, you see it, it's here on the desk, away from it. So I would start looking for the crisis after hearing my mother mention the fact that they actually were reading excerpts from things that appeared there in.
And that's how I learned about the crisis.
And then how did you come to sell subscriptions?
Well, I noticed that it was a, they had in the some column, some ad in the paper indicating that subscriptions were available.
And I said, one day, can I write to Roy Wilkins, who was the editor of the crisis? And I asked him, if I can't sell the crisis, and said, after all, if you're going to have a chapter of the NAACP,
in that then my language wasn't as it is today, as you can appreciate. But they said, my own means, but you must write the letter yourself.
I said, I will do that. So I did.
Did he write back?
I heard it. Got a note from him saying, we will be glad to have you sell the crisis magazine.
And any, any of that, it was typed, but it has his signature on it. And under there, it said editor, under his name.
And I was so proud to get the letter from the editor of the crisis. I was beside myself.
I bet. Now, can you share any details with us about what happened to your father as a result of his civil rights activities in 1939?
Oh, well, by 1939, the branch had been organized. He was the president, my mother was secretary. And during that those intervening years, my father had been arrested and taken to jail a few times.
But not formally charged. He was usually let go. However, one evening, he was brought home having been rather badly beaten.
And the two sheriffs are sheriff County of deputy. Anyway, they were law enforcement officials brought him home, opened the front door, which wasn't locked, because in those days you didn't lock your door until you went to bed at night, I think.
And I was home alone. My mother was at a meeting and they brought him in and put him on the dumped him on the couch, really, and said, take care of your paw. He's been hurt. And if he had not had connections, he would be in jail.
So I was, of course, frightened. And my, I was about nine at the time when my mother came home. I said to her, these two men brought him home. And they said to me, if he had did not have connections, he would be in jail.
I said, what does that mean? And she looked at me and she said, well, you, I guess I should tell you the county coroner of the, of Hayward County. His name was John severe was a doctor. And she said, Doctor severe probably asked them not to do anything to your father, because he, he's your grandmother's brother.
And I said, oh, it was half brother, because he was white. And of course, my grandmother was black. And he said that she said that Doctor severe is widely respected. And they, they tried to be as accommodating to help as they can.
When you were a student at Howard and, and later Washington Square campus of NYU in the 50s, you recall how you and other students felt about segregation and the lack of civil rights that most African Americans endured.
Well, I recall that we went to the, I think it was the Howard Theater in Washington, because you weren't welcomed in the other theaters as such, then except on a segregated basis. And we were concerned about that. Now this was during World War II that we were, that I was at Howard.
And we, during wartime, we were concerned about the, well, our good and welfare as students. And also why couldn't we go into many of the places which were still segregated in Washington.
And there was much discussion about that among us. We probably didn't do very much, but periodically one few of us would undertake to go into a restaurant and be denied entrance, but it never became a big issue in the sense of escalating into a rest at that point in time.
That was a little early. This is 43, 1943. And from 43 to 45, I was at Howard. And of course, we were also concerned about our studies. And there were a lot of uniformed men, boys, young men, I should say, on the campus as a part of the training program that the federal government had at that point in time.
Now you joined the NAACP on the staff in 1953, right before the Brown decision, and a little more than a year and a half before Emmett Till was murdered.
Share with us the mood of the NAACP staff and leadership and tell us about some of the personalities you met.
Oh, well, I don't want to give you a wandering answer. I came, started work in the fall of 1953 to do a special project for Gloucester Current, Director of Branches in Baltimore, Maryland, which was one of our largest branches in the country.
And it also had as its president, Dr. Lily M. Jackson, who was very well known throughout the country because she was very colorful and very strong and aggressive in a CP leader and well respected in Baltimore, and difficult to please.
So I was given Gloucester Current announced at a staff meeting, he introduced me as a temporary field secretary that I was going to Baltimore to do a six week membership campaign for the Baltimore branch.
The third good Marshall who was sitting a couple of seats away from me laughed loudly and said, Gloucester, why are you doing that to that girl? You should be ashamed of yourself.
Well, I did not know what that meant until I got to Baltimore and found how demanding and difficult it was to work for Mrs. Jackson.
But I did, we had a membership campaign which ran for six weeks and her daughter Juanita Jackson Mitchell, by that time, was a first organizer of the Youth Councils, of the Youth Program for the National NAACP.
So she worked with me and we eventually survived each other. I was baptized in that particular branch experience and worked at that point there was a man who was the president of Park Sausage, which was an early black corporation, which was, if not the first of his kind, was one of the first.
And one of the great fundus was a locally known man, well known man who was his income, supposedly it was derived from numbers and that type of thing.
So I became very friendly with those men and was able to get them to support the NAACP. But those were the extremes. Mrs. Jackson was a great church leader and these men were on the other side of this spectrum but they came together for the purpose of supporting this common cause.
So that had been Henry Parks? Yes, Henry G. Parks and the man was William Adams. I think they're there and he was always very nice to me. I always felt very comfortable and safe with him and Henry Parks. I was quite young then.
Let me take you back to the New York office and the people you met there, they're good Marshall whom you just mentioned a moment ago. Obviously you knew of him because you've been active in the NAACP as a young girl and in later years. What was your impressions of him when you met him?
Well, first I had to get accustomed to his language. I never heard so many cuss words in my life. But which was colorful. Nobody minded. You know, the way he was a wonderful racon tour and he had a tremendous sense of humor. And I said, this is very good Marshall.
But he was also very effective in getting you to do things and making difficult subjects sound easy. And he said, oh, Huxi will be going to Huxi Arkansas. He said, you'll be able to do that. It'll be a good first experience for you to get to know the parents there and the children.
And it'll be something that you'll remember for years to come. And of course, he was right. But it wasn't pie like he had claimed that it would be. But he was good at getting people to do things and also inspiring them is an exceptionally bright man. But it was all beneath this demeanor of gruffness and semi-cruidness. It's a manner he affected and he did well with making you comfortable with him.
And Royal Wilkins, what were your impressions of Royal Wilkins?
Very elegant man. One who was extremely similar to you concerned about the language and its use and the syntax and synod structure. And of course, I learned much about grandma and composition from Royal Wilkins who wrote beautifully. And he also was a very unpretentious person.
Did not want any ceremony. And he wrote the subway, which at that time was five cents going and coming to work. He did not want bodyguards or attendants. But he was a purist when he came to commit me to the association.
He wanted the staff to dedicate themselves to achieving the goals which were set out for them in terms of their work. And to it all times, it would be properly attired and achieved the right demeanor to present the NAACP as a wholesome, serious organization who had intelligent with people as its representatives.
And Walter White?
Walter White was colorful and he enjoyed people. He embraced people and he enjoyed the social interaction. And he also liked the spotlight.
Wilkins on the other hand did not seek the spotlight. He tolerated it, but Walter White thrived in the spotlight. And he also was because of his people skill and his inability to interact.
And he was able to get certain information in terms of doing his research. He was very fair. And he would presume to be Caucasian unless you would know otherwise.
So he was successful in going into places like Mississippi, Georgia and Arkansas and investigating lunches and other incidents and coming back without having been assaulted or thrown in jail.
So he enjoyed that kind of activity and the fact that he could live in these two worlds and it was effective.
A moment ago you mentioned Huxie, Arkansas and that took you into contact with Daisy Bates. What do you recall about Daisy Bates?
Mrs. Bates was a very dedicated civil rights worker. But she also had a sense of style and she enjoyed the spotlight as well. And she was not ever shy at that time.
The governor of Arkansas was Orville Falbus. And he was known to be anti-black, segregationist. And he was determined to keep these schools in Arkansas separate.
And of course, Daisy Bates on the other hand was, this is in the 50s now. This was just before 56. This was 55, 1955 when I first went, I'm sorry, 1954 when I first went to Little Rock. And then I went back two or three years after that during this period leading up to the integration of Central High.
Daisy was colorful, aggressive and she didn't mind the spotlight and very talkative. And she too was a people person. She was able to get branches and what we call the little people and the simple people, many of whom were barely literate to follow and come into the NAACP because at this point in time we were focusing on education.
And she was able to get their students, their children who were students, better education. And she was able to get many of them to become active in the units in the various cities and towns in Arkansas who had never been active before.
And the moment ago when you and I were talking, we mentioned Rosa Parks. What are your memories of Rosa Parks?
Rosa Parks is a very charming and gracious lady. And I think I said at one point, Leconic, she was a few words, but when she spoke, you listened to her. And she was very kind.
And in those days when you traveled as a field work of field secretary as I was, you would stay in the homes of NAACP people in various parts of the country.
And you would say they were officers of the branch. And once when I first went to Montgomery, I stayed with Mrs. Parks. This is before, of course, she left Alabama.
And she was a very, she and her husband both were very pleasant and comfortable people. They were quietly militant. They weren't bombastic.
And they didn't make a lot of noise about it. They just would act. And she would certainly, at that point, she was still secretary of the branch. And she was very determined that we should do more with our youth.
So she was focusing at that time a lot in getting the youth and my government to organize and to do certain steps in terms of preparing them to move forward in the integration movement.
And do you remember Ed Nixon, the president of Montgomery branch, Pobend Car Porter?
Yes, I do. I do.
What do you recall of him? Well, he was a very dedicated person with a strong commitment to civil rights. And he was committed to the NAACP and the way he believed that we had to have an integrated society, if we as blacks were to thrive and achieve in this country.
And he was one of the few voices who would withstand a lot of the pressure in Alabama to take a stand and also refused, he refused to give up the membership roles of the NAACP in Alabama when the Attorney General demanded it.
And then after that period, you may recall that the NAACP was banned from operating in Alabama.
You had been at the NAACP about a year and a half when newscombs that this boy Emmett Till has been found dead in a river in Mississippi.
Do you remember hearing the news about that and what the reaction of the people in the office here were?
Yes, I remember. It was considered in our office to be a great tragedy because just before then, and I'm sorry, I can't remember the town, one of our branch presidents had been killed in Mississippi.
Gus Cowns. I think, yeah. And we were in the throes of that. And because we had encouraged, we, the NAACP, were encouraging them to continue the voter education registration campaign.
And this brought about his death, the branch presidents. And this young child, as we, as he was presumed to be and was killed, it was felt at that point that Mississippi was just completely going out of bounds.
And then nothing was sacred or safe in the state. And the NAACP really had to stay behind its people to help them and to keep them from having to be cave in or to become too intimidated to keep the movement going.
Because if the NAACP didn't continue to thrive in NAACP or function, I should say not thrive, then we would not be able to do anything about an Emmett Till.
And this was the great concern, whether this would stop the movement.
Do you have any remembering any interaction with Mamie Bradley, his mother, Emmett Till's mother?
Yes, I arranged a tour, I guess we could, of NAACP branches, for Mrs. Bradley to visit.
And actually, a company in her for some of the time, to some of the cities, which we arranged for her to visit.
She was a woman who was very articulate. And as she campaigned or visited the units across the country, I should say, she grew more militant and more informed and became more involved.
And then, of course, she started speaking more forcefully and demanding, making demands, which should be met in terms of acquisition of civil rights and justice for her son.
And she insisted on open for example for opening the casket when he was funeralized in Chicago, which was quite an experience from one to have.
To see him lying in the casket and showing the evidences of his having been killed.
And before we began this interview, you and I were talking about Clarence Norris, one of the Scotsboro boys.
Tell that story once again, how you came to know him.
Our office moved to 1790 Broadway off Columbus Circle. And one day this man came into the office and the switchboard operator called me to say, we have a man here who needs help, which is often that happened.
And usually, at that point, I was, I think, executive assistant to the Roy Wilkins or assistant director between Mr. Wilkins and John Dr. Morselle.
And so I went out to see this man and it developed his name as Clarence Norris.
And did you recognize him?
I'm sorry. Did you recognize him?
Not at first, but then after he started talking, I realized that I had seen this pictures and that he was one of the Scotsboro boys.
And he said, I know.
He was a fugitive, was he not?
Yes, he was. He had been for several years.
So this was not new. I mean, we knew this in the NAACP that he had escaped.
I didn't know where he was and didn't know he'd walked into the office. Did you?
No, I have a faintest idea. He was in the New York area.
And this had to be, I guess, in the late 60s when this happened.
And he said, I went to the old office years ago, meaning 20 West Florida Street.
And I met a miss, the lady who was the office manager and he described, I said, Miss Branch.
And he said, yes. And he said, if she's here, she'll help me.
And I said, you need help. And he said, yes.
So I called Bobby Branch and asked if I could bring him around to her.
And she said, yes. And she remembered him.
And our office manager then, as you might recall, Bobby Branch embraced people.
And she was very, very, very, uh, egregious.
And she welcomed him and said, I'll help you.
What do you need? And he needed some money, of course.
And he said, his wife, I believe that first time. I think his wife was ill.
She said, well, let me see if Mr. Wilkins is here. And I'll take you over to meet him.
And I told her he wasn't there, but Dr. Morselle was.
So he met Dr. Morselle and they talked. And Dr. Morselle was a very thoughtful.
If we can't do, provide some further assistance.
And Willie Nare said that, yes, I need assistance.
I wanted to clear my name before I die.
And that's how this relationship, again, with him was resumed.
After the NAC many, many years ago, had been instrumental in helping them until a problem of a political problem arose
where the Communist Party became involved. And the NACP stepped aside.
That was when he was a much younger man.
Shortly after they were having been arrested for the rape to begin with.
And he had escaped and came to New York City.
And now he's coming to the NAACP and making a request for an assistance for a pardon.
And how did that work?
Well, actually for money it was his first request.
And then he made, when he met and talked with John Morselle.
He said he wanted, Morselle said, we want to see how we can be, provide some meaningful assistance for you,
meaning to try to get them settled into a job and whatever.
And he says, I want to clear my name.
And they said, I want to clear my name before I die.
And that's really when our General Counsel, not that visit.
But it was arranged for him to give him some money and for him to return.
And when he returned, it was then he talked with our General Counsel, Mr. Wilkins,
that spoke to Nathaniel Jones, who was our General Counsel at that point.
And I asked if you would join Wilkins when, Norris, Mr. Norris, came back into the office.
And from that point on, Nathaniel Jones became the person who was exploring how the legal department,
our legal department could help him.
And he assigned one of the bright young attorneys whose name was James Myerson to work on the issue of getting a full pardon for Willie Norris.
And eventually Myerson and Wilkins and Jones and Norris, go to Alabama and secure his name.
Meet the governor and the attorney general and get a full pardon from him, from them for Willie.
That's a wonderful, wonderful story.
Following that, the book was written, the last of the Scotsboro Boys.
Many young people who came involved in the NAACP through Youth Council.
For time you worked as field secretary and director of education, what were your goals for the programs that involved young people?
Well, first, I should say I was never a director of education.
June Shagalong was. I was a director of a lot of things. I can't remember all of the jobs I had.
Every five years, I would transfer to a new job.
I was an assistant director to the executive and then a director and then finally director of operations and director of programs under which education fell at that point.
And I'm sorry, I forgot the other part of the question.
What were the goals that you worked on that involved young people? What were the programs that you worked on that involved young people?
Well, the programs which involved young people on which I worked early on were AXO, which is the academic cultural, scientific Olympics.
And they subsequently added Afro to the title.
And that was for the purpose of developing academic excellence in academic excellence and general achievement.
As far as youth were concerned, they could be in any field, any of 24 fields, arts and science and the literary in general.
And the youth were organized on a local level, according to the program. Now this program was founded by Benjamin Hooks and Vernon Jarrett, who was a newspaper reporter from Chicago.
And Benjamin Hooks became the successor to Roy Wilkins. And we organized units across the country, similar to youth units, with an advisor for AXO.
The idea was to recruit those who showed promise locally and then do have local competitions, then regional competitions, then national competitions.
And the program is still going strong today. There are some 600 AXO units across the country, who are actively engaged.
The one here in Metropolitan New York is where we are at the moment, is the largest one, because there are some 17 units who ranches who participate.
And if you count the local branch participation, this is probably the largest African-American talent-based scholarship program in the country.
Yes, and the most enduring. And of course, scholarships are given, awards are given, medals are given, at the national convention.
And we have had such people, as I was trying to think of some people who have come through the AXO program.
I think there's a young man who's a conductor of a symphony who appears at Lincoln Center, who was an AXO graduate.
And we have others, I don't want to try to name names, because I'll leave out some.
No, but they're a distinguished group of achievers.
Yes, absolutely.
A moment ago, you talked about the Roar Wilkins succeeding Walter White, Walter White died.
Yes, he did.
And Roar Wilkins was named to succeed him.
Was there any, do you remember any discussion whether or not Roar Wilkins should have succeeded him, or was there another candidate or...?
No, not at that time, because Walter White died in 1955.
Suddenly, he had been ill and on leave, but Roar Wilkins had been serving in...
He had a leave of Apsons, Walter White did.
Right.
And Roar Wilkins had been serving as administrator, and in his absence, the executive, he took over the duties of executive secretary.
And when Walter White died while on leave, Roar Wilkins, after the Serp funeral, of course, at the next board meeting, I believe it was, in the spring board meeting, was named as his successor.
There had been some earlier discussions, prior to this, when Walter White had gone on leave, had a leave of Apsons before.
And then, when Walter White went around the world, I believe, a few years before that.
And there was some discussion then about who would be, whether Roar Wilkins would be his successor.
And succeeding Roar Wilkins was Benjamin Hooks.
Yes.
To describe him.
He was a Baptist minister, and a dramatic Baptist minister.
And his art and historical skills were great, and he enjoyed demonstrating, as he spoke.
He inspired our constituents, whereas, while Roar Wilkins was an intellectual type speaker, who laid the facts out in elegant prose, Mr. Hooks demonstrated his features frequently by his physical activities on the podium.
And he used the, shall I say, the gospel approach in terms of inspiring our constituents.
And he was effective. He got the kind of visceral response, which people enjoy during the course of speeches.
And he could inspire them also, not just to respond to him, but to become actively engaged in the work of the NAACP.
He kept our constituents committed in the units across the country. He tried to travel as much as he could, because they are the connection between the National Office and the constituents.
If they aren't actively engaged in the 50 states across the country, then the NAACP's presence is not being brought to the fore as it should be, and as it to show how forceful it can be.
And that's the only organization of its kind, which has, shall I say, 1700 units in the 50 states plus some 500 youth and college units.
Why do you think it is that the NAACP's accomplishments and achievements are not as well known as one would think they'd be after all the organizations 100 years old plus, and has a remarkable record of achievement and accomplishment.
Yet it doesn't seem to be as well known as one would think it would be. Why do you think that is?
I have no idea except that we, as a people, don't focus on history and our heritage. And the NAACP was here before most of all of us were here at this point.
But as it has achieved many accomplishments, and actually it has affected the order of life for all of us, whatever color we are, what is more far reaching than the Interstate Travel Bill, for example, the school integration, desegregation of the public schools, or the public accommodations laws, where everybody could get access to the public.
But what happens, I believe, is we forget our history, we live in the period, and then we take for granted what there is, and do not retain it as an achievement which had been caused by the hard work of those who came on before us.
We don't really, as a people in this country, not just the black people, but we don't really focus on our own American history and what has happened at the various periods and the transitions through which we have gone. We forget.
And then take for granted, this is my right, it's here now, we don't think about how it was in the past. And the NAACP has been actually forgotten a lot of times when it was the only instrument which was able to achieve certain things which we now enjoy. And I don't have an answer.
Well, I don't either. Let me mention some organizations, some of which have come and gone in the span of the NAACP's history, and just give me your impressions of them. The Southern Christian Leadership Conference.
I think the SCLC was an effective organization and the sense that it brought to the fore in the minds of the public that the religious leaders in this country were engaged in and active in terms of passing the word.
And we are proud of our civil rights and providing inspiration and leadership to their congregations throughout the country that we should be mindful and become engaged in this struggle. And we can do by showing ourselves and lending our voices.
The SCLC was flexible because its leaders could go from one community to the other and call together the religious leaders in a given community to provide a voice for a particular cause and a particular action.
And I think it was helpful in that respect in terms of setting before us actively through the pulpits of what it was we needed to do and what we must do.
What about the student nonviolent coordinating committee, my old organization, Snake?
Oh yes, well you know more about that than I do. I certainly think that these sit-ins were extraordinary in the sense that they opened the eyes of the O-fokes, the adults in the country.
But this I can do also and a simple act of walking into a cafe or a ten-cent store as they had been lunch counter and sitting there and saying I'm not going to move.
That's something all of us could do. But the students demonstrated that this is something that had not been done and that we're going to do it. And they did.
And it was impressive and it inspired us as older people to really go out and demonstrate and say if our youth can do it, our children can do it, then why won't we do it?
What about the Congress of Raisley Quality Corps?
The Corps was a little more intellectual and it had an excellent leader in James Farma who formerly worked for the NAACP as our program director.
So many of these leaders by the way of the other organizations had gotten their grounding and their foundations in the NAACP, such as Martin Luther King did, Jr.
and his father had been active in the NAACP before him. So the Corps was more integrated than the other groups were in terms of racial integration.
And it appealed to a younger group in general, students and young adults, and they were concerned about demonstrating in black and white the acquisition of the goals they wanted to achieve.
And they had a certainly an impact, I believe, in terms of encouraging non blacks to participate actively in the Civil Rights Movement.
What about the Black Panther Party?
Well, the Black Panther Party, I believe, had the energy and the ambition and a sense in my judgment of misdirection eventually, it became, it started as a militant group wanting to use its power and apply it actively, then it veered toward separation and separatism.
And the Black Power became an instrument in my judgment to, shall I say, encourage and focus on black separatism, which I believe, and I'm convinced it was then self-defeating and would be today.
I think many people think of the NAACP primarily as a legal organization, as an organization that achieved change through legal means through the courts.
Do you think this fairly characterizes the NAACP?
No.
Why not?
Well, one of the first executive orders that President Roosevelt, not one of the first ones, but an executive order that President then, President Roosevelt,
the issue about the armed services, the preliminary one, was done as a result of the NAACP's lobbying and campaigning.
And the fact that Mrs. Roosevelt was on our board of directors, Walter White and Mrs. Roosevelt had a good relationship, and it was possible to get Mrs. Roosevelt to work with Walter White and Philip Randolph and get the President, then Roosevelt, to understand that an executive order,
to desegregating federal installations, should be issued. And of course, that wasn't integration, but it was a first step, and that was done without any legal action.
And the Civil Rights Law, the first Civil Rights Law was achieved primarily through lobbying and through, under the ages of Clarence, the Washington Bureau, again, that historic act was passed by Congress as a result of lobbying, which was, it was within the confines of the Galaté, but it wasn't illegal act.
And so I think in the public accommodations are all the same thing. So there are so many things which widely affect our society, which the NAACP inspired, led, and accomplished, which were not legal actions, such actions as far as litigation is concerned.
But again, this may be redundant. Why is it that we still think of, or many people think of, the NAACP as primarily a legal organization, and these other activities that you've mentioned aren't associated in the public mind with the NAACP?
I suspect one of the reasons is, our law has appeared before the Supreme Court so many times. Form of General Counsel Robert Carter, it made some 36 appearances before the Supreme Court, and won about 30 of those cases.
And before that, Tia, a Thurgood Marshall, before he became a Justice when he was NAACP Counsel, appeared before the Supreme Court. I can't remember the exact number now, but it was more than two dozen times. And of course, most of those cases were won.
And this, of course, press the publicity of the winning of these cases, set in the minds of people that legal action was responsible, or is responsible for our progress in this country, and to an important extent it is.
But without the grassroots lobbying, and without the work, the meticulous work of footing before our congressmen, both on local, state and federal levels, the need to enact certain laws and the pressure from the grassroots.
We would not be where we were today, where we are today.
Skipping to another personality, do you think Malcolm X had any effect during his life on the NAACP or sub-rights, generally speaking, and did his death, or his murder, have an impact on the NAACP, particularly in northern cities, northern communities?
Well, this is one person's opinion. I think certainly he demonstrated the fact that discipline could be achieved in leadership. And he exercised discipline in the sense of the followers who became committed to his movement, the movement which he led,
believed and committed themselves to conforming to the guidelines and expectations. And these were, in so many instances, young men who had been street people, who had no commitment as such, except to survive the best way they could for themselves, and they became a part of a cohesive group, and interacting with each other, and willing to help each other.
And then project this onto the community. I think that's one excellent cause he served. And I believe that his death did have a serious impact, because of the fact that it represented the death of a leader who had a following that over whom he had, shall I say, such vast experience,
that they could be effectively banned to get banned together, to achieve progress by folks who have been formally on the streets, and who have formally not been engaged in any meaningful activity. And this was an important example. It seems to me for those of us in civil rights, not that we agreed with all of his philosophy.
But do you think you could feel a measurable impact that he had, particularly after his death, that there were people who, within the NAACP perhaps, who said, perhaps in some ways we should emulate his dedication, his conviction?
I think there were some people like that, and I will measureably there were, especially among our youth. They felt that he had the right idea in terms of his discipline and his rhetoric, which became more bland before he died than it was when he began, when he was preaching almost anarchy at one point in time.
And he modified his position to develop pressure on the power structure by threatening and also showing that he represented a force in the community, in the society, I should say, not just the community.
I think that this impressed, especially our younger adults and youth, in the NAACP, you had a reaction that they believed that he was on the right track, or he's a good example for us to follow.
You were married to an attorney who worked with the NAACP to affect change. How did his work construct your lives together?
Well, before I knew him, John, he was chairman of the Legal and Redress Committee of Detroit branch, having been born in Michigan and reared in Michigan.
And when I first went to Detroit to work with the NAACP branch there in Arthur Johnson, and it's executive secretary, we were organizing the first Freedom Fund Life Membership dinner.
And at that point, the Legal Redress Committee of the Detroit branch was very active, and they had won two or three cases in the Michigan before the Michigan Supreme Court involving housing and education.
And John was the lead lawyer in those particular cases, and it was after then that I got to know him so that I always felt that the Detroit branch was an excellent example of the kind of activities and accomplishments that an NAACP branch should undertake.
And of course, the work of the Legal Committee actually got commendations from the National Office on Third World Marshal, who was in our General Counsel.
So that kind of thing impressed me about the importance of having a varied scope of activity in the Civil Rights Movement.
And of course, he, on the other hand, was supportive of the Detroit branch's other activities.
So we were, shall I say, compatible in the sense, and we share an interest in terms of civil rights.
That wasn't a reason we married, but that was one of the reasons of the first, the common interest in the early days.
Well, think about the Detroit branch. From your perspective, and what you've seen over the years, what is it that makes branch A effective, efficient, hard fighting, and so on, and branch B lackluster, sleepy, do nothing?
It's leadership. I believe it's the leadership. The extent of which leadership inspires the board and the members will be the extent to which they respond and become creative.
And are inspired to become creative and do things in a more positive and forceful nature.
I think the key is in the kind of leadership branch it has, branches have across the country.
Let me ask you to talk about some occasions in the past over time when the leadership of the NAACP has faced real challenges or difficult circumstances.
I'm thinking about the barring of the NAACP and Alabama, the lawsuit against the NAACP and Mississippi, because of the boycott.
Tell us, talk about those things. How did the people here respond to that?
When you say here, are you talking about New York and New York?
About the National Office.
Well, they were deeply, first of all, they were deeply, they were defiant one.
We are not going to give those membership list up. That was the first thing.
Second, we've got to find a way to work around this and do continue our work.
So we had, I had employed recently Mrs. Ruby Hurley, who was sent to Alabama to organize units of the NAACP in the southeast region, which is the Confederate States.
Mrs. Hurley had been in Alabama not too long. I guess probably less than a year doing this in organizing units headquartered in Birmingham, as I recall.
She moved after the NAACP was banned. The office there was moved to Atlanta.
But as a result of that, she and some other NAACP volunteer workers would visit these states in which the NAACP had been banned.
Alabama, Mississippi, Alabama, Georgia, not Georgia, but Alabama.
And I forgot the other state. There were two states whose membership roles were taken.
It would not be given up, I should say. In any case, the thing I wanted to say is Mrs. Hurley and other volunteers went almost sort of ticiously into communities to work again,
and then memberships of the NAACP and to organize certain things like getting petition signed and to get them to organize, to go to the polls, to register, to go to the courthouse or wherever to register and vote.
But it was done under the cover of night, so to speak, without the banner of the NAACP in the daytime having these meetings.
It made it, shall I say, dangerous. Mrs. Hurley was threatened many times. Her life was threatened, and she was in danger doing this.
But she was a spokesperson who was able to get these groups in these various states in Alabama and Georgia and Mississippi to come together to agree to do certain things in terms of continuing the fight for civil rights in their communities.
And what about when the local leadership would be under attack as in the case of Medgarvars assassination? What was the New York headquarters office response?
Well, his response was to send people into Mississippi to fill the void, actually to reassure the people that the NAACP was continuing its fight with Medgar's death.
This was just even more important that we demonstrate that we were not intimidated by the fact that he was killed.
So actually his brother took the position, took over the position of field director for the state of Mississippi.
And he's still there in Mississippi, eventually became mayor of Philadelphia, I believe it was Charles.
But this is the kind of thing the NAACP was forced to do in order to make sure that the people, its constituents had examples of our continuing the work of the association one way or the other.
And what was Medgarvars like? You surely knew him.
Yes, I worked with Medgarvars. I was sent to Mississippi in the 60s to interview farmers who had been denied credit because of who was subjected to economic reprisals, because of their NAACP activities continuing to go to the polls to register and vote.
And Medgarvars and I as a field director, he would drive to various places because this is the best way to get there.
And we went into the Delta area to get an interview farmer, the farmers.
So I could take these reports back to New York to see how we could help them to survive the winter.
And being denied credit over the winter season, it meant they had no means of getting sued because that was the tradition you get credit for the next four months.
And then when this spring came, you were able to start planting and you would be able to start paying the bills again. And all of that credit was cut off.
So we traveled, I guess, we spent about at that point about two weeks doing this one at one particularly difficult time when our farmers, our farmers with being subjected economic reprisals, we had had two branch presidents who had been killed just before this particular time.
And it was difficult to believe that these people would continue to carry on like this because the situation was so oppressive in Mississippi.
And we were driving one night and I had taken off my shoes and I felt something on the floor which was cold.
And I said to them, what is this kid, maybe I can move it. He said, well, that's my shotgun, you have your feet on. So of course my feet flew up.
But this is just to give you an idea of the sense of the environment. And we would drive each night from wherever we went, where at Yazoo or whatever town into which we'd gone at night again, not to further endanger the farmers and the people who were being subjected to these reprisals.
And drive back to Mount Bio which is a black town in that area in which there was a motel. And we would go back to stay at that motel and then start out the next day and planning to arrive in the sort of the evening to visit the farmers.
And this is the way in which you had to function in those days out of Jackson, where you walked around in the daytime and did your interviews.
Does that answer the question?
Yes, it does.
I mean, for you move on to the next one.
Okay.
So I need to start a new tape.
Do you need or if you want a glass of water or anything?
No, but I could go to the bathroom.
Okay.
I want to remember.
I don't know what I did yesterday.
That's...
About them on first meeting.
Well, I've really met them first at a meeting.
Mrs. Bates would plan to have them gather, not necessarily in NACP meeting as such, but just to meet with them, to talk with them.
I would say to inspire them and to sort of inject discipline to keep them together in other words.
And they were individual personalities.
I did not get to know them well.
I only knew them as a group in the course of the meetings because they were carefully tended in the sense of for their own security.
And so, before the year before, the Central High School began the actual process of integration.
This is the free, I forget the year, but it was 55 or 56.
And then they actually entered the next year in the fall.
But the thing that impressed me was one, the quiet determination of Ernest Greene.
I remembered him who later became a member of the NACP Board of Directors.
And another one who I remember is Minigene Brown, who had a special 30 personality.
And some of them acquired and others sort of follow us in this sense.
I'm sure they had their own individual personalities outside of the group.
But those are the ones I remember most particularly as being responsive and actively ready to go forward with the process of going to school.
And the others were, I wouldn't say they were follow-ups, I would just say that they were engaged in a quiet and fashion.
And they were less for civil as a less active in the process, except that they wanted to finish their schooling.
They all had that.
What about?
I don't know what I'm going to do.
Let me ask about two women from South Carolina, whom you may have met.
Septima Clark and Bernice Robinson, the cousins, I believe.
I met them, but I didn't really know them, except by, you know, reputation that they were very active and engaged.
But I really didn't know them.
What about Ella Baker, who worked at the NAACP?
Yes, after she worked for the NAACP, it's when I met her because she was a very forceful personality.
And she became focused on our youth, if you recall, and actually was involved in the founding of the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
She worked in our Department of Branches before I came on board to the NAACP.
And she spent considerable time traveling around the country, organizing branches and eliciting memberships and developing membership campaigns,
and instructing our branches how to do that.
And she was a very forceful woman.
And I was always impressed by her determination and her aggressiveness.
And at that time, when I first started working with NAACP, you didn't have that many women who were working in levels up beyond the support levels in the organization.
And in the work arena period, in other organizations as well, most of the females were assistants or secretaries, or that type of thing in the NAACP.
And they had a few, for example, Lucille Black, who came in at age 17 as a secretary.
And she worked her way up to become membership secretary, it was called then, of the NAACP.
And Bobby Branch, who came in as a clerk, who wound up as office manager.
They, obviously, we hired certain NAACP in the legal department.
There were always one or two females.
And then when I came on board, one of the few female executives was June Shagelof, who was a field director in education, who traveled to and worked to providing information and support for the legal department on our legal programs.
And not a woman, but Jack Greenberg. What do you remember about Jack Greenberg?
Well, he was a young lawyer who came on, he was on board about a year before I came on, and I got to know him quite well.
And very active, and we were contemporaries in terms of age also, we were about the same age.
And he worked well with, they're good marshall, he was a good, I believe they would call either associate or assistant counsels during that period, the young lawyers who were working on the NAACP.
And he was focusing a lot on education, on the education cases.
That was one of the things that Jack focused on during the period when they were putting together cases in the various communities, about six or eight communities around primarily in the south or as far north as Kansas, or west as Kansas.
Which eventually became the group of cases led by Brown to go up through the process onto the Supreme Court.
And Bob Carter, what do you remember of having been those days?
Oh yes, well Bob was the associate, I guess, he was a second attorney to third good who was still in a CP counsel at this point when I came on board.
And remained so for the next few years.
And Bob was the quieter one, but he also was the one who reached out in the communities and spent a lot of time and effort putting together the South Carolina cases, for example.
And he eventually fled in a couple of instances during those trials before the Supreme Court.
But he has a wonderful mind and he was meticulous and concerned about amassing the information in an orderly way.
And he spent a lot of time questioning it and really feeling you got the feeling that he was being too meticulous, difficult, but it wasn't at all.
He had this commitment to make sure that nothing was left unturned and no eye was not dotted.
And as a result, it became sort of labor the various at times, the work for the people who were working with him, that is the assistance and the researchers.
But it was in the final analysis, it was what had to be done.
It was not easy, but he was willing to put himself into the task of getting this part of the work done.
Do you want to stop that? Can you hear the talking down there?
A moment ago, you mentioned that when you began working here at the NAACP, the employment sort of paralleled what we saw in the larger society, that is women in clergy in clerical roles and men in the executive roles.
Over time, I guess, that's changed, but it also strikes me that it contrasts with a different picture in the branch system.
In the branch system, women are presidents, women do serve in roles that maybe they weren't expected to serve in.
But how has this situation changed over time?
You mean in terms of the...
The little women in the NAACP?
Well, actually, when you think about women's contributions to the NAACP, without the women, we wouldn't have an NAACP.
The first, the person who was responsible for generating the organizing meeting was a woman.
And of course, ever since then, we have women, have had women in key roles, not in the majority, but in the very key roles, which were responsible for the women.
For the evolution of the NAACP, I think in terms of people like Mrs. Daisy Lamkin, who was a member of our national board from Pittsburgh, who traveled around the country, garnering memberships, and helping to organize branches.
And that was back in the 40s, 30s and 40s, before it became fashionable or popular for women to travel.
You have women who have subsequently held positions in the NAACP nationally as program directors and as leaders of various divisions.
For example, Eltheos Simmons actually succeeded, Clarence Mitchell, as head of the Washington Bureau.
We had Constance Baker Modley in the legal department, who eventually moved up to the leadership role in the legal defense fund in the NAACP legal defense fund, subsequently.
Mrs. Francis Hooke's, who founded women, had no defined place in the organization.
And Mrs. Francis Hooke's, the wife of Benjamin Hooke's, founded when women in the NAACP, which gave them a structure in which to function and reach out and do the things in the NAACP that they had been doing, but in an organized and recognizable fashion.
You wound up having Margaret Bush Wilson become the second female to be chairman of the board of the NAACP.
And then Vice Chair has developed Roslyn Brock, who has succeeded you as Chair.
Women have been, as a matter of fact, I don't know if you know this in your research of the NAACP, but the March, the 19 March in New York here in protests to lynch in the silent March.
And the research in Arkansas and of the lynchings and then on into Georgia was done by a female who brought the report back for Dr. Dubois, who was involved at that point in terms of massing the information, which was the basis on which the,
that March was constructed and held as a result of that report she brought back in 1918.
And the March subsequently was held in 1919 after the information on the lynching and the murders that she had investigated was submitted really through our Washington Bureau to the federal government.
It was felt that nothing would be done so this March evolved. And of course Dr. Dubois was given the greater publicity for having or, you know, been the leader, but actually the responsibility of putting that together and causing it to happen was the report done by a female.
Did you have any interaction with Dr. Dubois?
No, no, he was, he was even before my time.
But I mean, do you ever run into him? You both live in New York. I know it's a big city.
I met him, but and and had written him for a copy of one of his documents, one of his papers. And he wrote back saying he'd be delighted to send it to send $5.
So, I sent the $5 and got the paper. But he was an interesting, a gather from those who knew him in our office.
They would relate stories about Dr. Dubois and how a servant he could be and, and, and.
Did you share a story?
Well, I don't, I don't remember them well enough to tell. So I won't, I won't undertake to do that and misread his and mislead the history.
What would you like the public to know about the work you've done here at the NAACP?
Well, not really. I'm not really, never thought about the public knowing much about what I do.
My concern as far as my being a part of the NAACP was to do what I could in my small way to make its leaders and, and that's my satisfaction.
But I'm sure your parents told you don't hide your light under a bushel and there must be something here that you did done here that you are proud of among other things.
Among all the things you've done here must be things that stand out, something that you're happy that you did.
I'd have to guess what I thought to that. I can't remember.
You know, I've had to do a lot of different things over the years. I wound up getting into that position where it was felt that I was flexible and I could fit into a lot of different places doing a lot of different jobs.
The reason I'm still probably at the NAACP in one sense, I worked as a full-time person until 1997, was every five years I moved into a different department, a different job.
And I have held, see, probably about eight or ten jobs and almost every department in the association except it's accounting department.
But the satisfaction I got was one learning how the NAACP function and how I could make it more effectively function in that particular area.
For example, I went from the branch department as an assistant to Gloucester-Carran and a field secretary at large.
Not that was my baptism. If you traveled in the early 50s and as a female, a young unattached, I wasn't married in female, it was quite an experience.
First, you had to be sure that in the cities where you went and the meetings and whatever, that you were properly on your guard in terms of the male female interaction.
And then you had to be concerned about the branch president who was an authority, but you were a young female.
So you had that as a thing traveling in those days, you know, it's no issue in later years.
But it was unusual, apparently, for young unattached women to travel into the high way, you know, the count of biways are travel.
So that was an education. I thanked the NAACP for educating me, giving me the experience of being educated.
But each time you had to be careful, you had to learn diplomacy, you had to learn self-protection, and you had to do your job.
Now, all of that was combined in the process when I started work for the NAACP.
And I won't go into all the departments, but I've worked in virtually every department.
And for me, it was always a good feeling when they have said to me, well, you have done the basic organizing and alignment of the ship department.
Now, we need you as an executive assistant to the executive secretary.
So we would like to get you to move into the executive department.
And so I did. And I would then go from, I was a director of operations at one point, director of programs.
I wound up being a development director with the money, with the education I got in the NAACP and the knowledge.
I would use that for marketing, and then I, of course, wound up going to school, taking courses so that I would know the technical side of fundraising.
And then you had to learn how to be, say, under respect competencies.
And I've learned an awful lot about the leaders of the association.
And, you know, the executive directors primarily, and what makes them tick and how they do this and the other, what they shouldn't do or what they did do and shouldn't have.
But it was a part of the education in terms of understanding what the NAACP needed and what they needed as leaders.
So it's hard for me to say to you, I'm most proud of this or that or the other.
There's probably something I am most proud of. But I don't, I guess I'm proud that we were able to keep the parents inspired in Huxie to keep the children and walking the children to school every day.
And getting them and that school board voluntarily desegregated at schools, but the parents needed support and help.
So I got a sense of satisfaction of walking with these children, holding their hands, going to school with them.
And then they are persevering so that they wound up not being forced out of the schools.
It's hard for me to pick an item like an accomplishment. I don't know what accomplishment I might have achieved that would be worth talking about in the sense of an event.
Because it would be cumulatively affected. I've been able to serve, I think.
Well, I'm not answering your question. Let me ask one more.
In Huxie and in other places where you went traveling for the NAACP, were there times when you felt inferior life?
After what says, you know, a funny thing about it is when you're in danger and like Megan, I were traveling around and I didn't realize I had my feet on the shotgun there.
And being intimidated and going across fields, cotton fields and other fields at night to get to a local meeting, which was being held.
And the fact that there were police patrolling in the Delta area.
My reaction of fear has come after I've gotten through it because you don't have time to be afraid.
I have found that after I've graded, you are stupid. How could you get in such a situation out in the middle of nowhere and nobody on whom to call?
But the fear comes as far as I can recall after it has, you've gotten out of that particular physical situation.
And it does come. But later, I think if you're pushed to do something or have to do it, you're more focused on, how can I get this done?
That is my experience. And my parents always said to me, you're an idiot if you get afraid while you're doing something because you've become your own worst enemy.
And you act without logic or reason. And you don't want to do that. You want to plan and try to do what is most appropriate to safeguard yourself and reach that goal, whatever it is.
But some things that I look at now, as I said, some of the travels in the 50s, and going into, say, a spend of somewhere in Arkansas, traveling to the various branches.
And small branches like Eldorado, or El Dorado, I think they call it Arkansas. And cotton plant Arkansas, I'll never hear of it until I went there.
And places where the white citizens in the town, the power structure, the worst thing that they could learn was that a visitor from the NACP branch from New York was coming in to stir trouble.
And that was a kind of environment in which I worked. And so many instances during that, say, it was five-year period that I served as a field secretary.
And I guess I must have worked in about 40 states. And some of them, you know, the West and North were not as intimidating as the South, but I traveled frequently in Mississippi, also in Georgia, also Alabama.
And those states were the tensions were greatest, and the people were most fearful, including the local units were exceedingly careful.
And that was a learning experience for me about people and how you could survive and accommodate yourself to staying in their homes and feeling that you were bringing them danger.
Because the fact that I was there sleeping in their room, and there's nothing secret eventually that town knows what the folks are doing.
So those experiences have, I think, made me, maybe more humane today, and made me understand that people are imperfect, but they are worth any help you can give to ameliorate the circumstances of problems and negative problems.
And I think the NACP has had that kind of an effect in communities where it has functioned as an entity.
People have felt that they could get help going to the NACP, that there would be something done in their behalf.
I think they believed that, and I believe in large measure they still do.
And we on the other hand should be accountable and responsible, and our leaders should be effective in the sense that they should be able to reach out to people and inspire their confidence about what they do as an example.
And any help you can give to make that happen should be given.
I still have an answer to your question.
Okay, that's okay. Thank you for giving your help. Thank you. I think we're through.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.